quería comenzar esta conferencia con
esta frase de mandela que nos invitan
quizás un pelín a reflexionar sobre la
importancia de la educación en nosotros
en las personas
vemos como mandela dice que la educación
es el arma más poderosa para poder
cambiar el mundo y tanto que lo es la
educación permite que el hijo del país
se convierta en un ingeniero agrícola la
educación permite que bueno que el hijo
del albañil pues se convierta en un
arquitecto y la educación me ha
permitido a mí estar hoy aquí y porque
os digo esto yo crecí en situación de
pobreza en el uruguay y cuando les hablo
de pobreza no me refiero a que no nos
daba para terminar el mes es que no
había nada no teníamos nada máxime
teniendo en cuenta que bueno mi padre y
mi madre se llevaban unos 25 años de
diferencia y mi madre bueno a veces
tenía unas ausencias más largas que
otras y ahí nos encontramos nosotros en
un barrio muy difícil de la periferia de
la ciudad de montevideo que se conoce
con el nombre de barrio borró hablar del
barrio borró implicaba estar y entrar en
la zona más roja de la ciudad donde
estaban las bandas de narcotraficantes
de delincuentes de tratas de blanca y
nosotros estábamos ahí
hermanos al punto de que no tenía
mostrada para comer un día
no había nevera tampoco no podía salir y
decir pues mira como esto no ya nada y
entonces estábamos solos con mi hermano
y me acuerdo que cogimos un ladrillo y
comenzamos con un destornillador azul es
como unas rendijas y le pusimos ahí una
resistencia y tenía un fuego y cogimos
una olla pusimos un poco de agua y lo
único que encontramos para ir un poco de
sal y una cabeza de ajo y esta noche
comimos eso
al otro día le dije a mi hermano mira
sabes una cosa vamos a hacer un carro
vamos a hacer un carro cogimos un carro
le pusimos dos rueditas unos palos y nos
fuimos a un mercado agrícola y a partir
de ahí me di cuenta que en este mercado
agrícola podíamos comer la partida y le
dije a mi hermano no vamos a pasar más
hambre porque vamos a comer porque estoy
aquí hoy con vosotros por la educación
la educación pondera a los pobres y no
solamente por la educación porque
alguien en este mundo fue tan solidario
que me apadrinó que fueron los
sacerdotes de la gruta de lourdes misión
pues mira a ver tú quieres estudiar pues
mira te vamos a dar los boletos te vamos
a dar un poco de dinero para que puedas
ir a estudiar y ahí me dieron y lo que
significaba el dinero unos boletos para
el bus ir y venir a estudiar y hoy estoy
aquí gracias a la educación que he
recibido a esa educación que hoy por hoy
esta educación
tendría que ser una educación como él
hablaba diferente y no transformadora
hoy por hoy vemos que los niños van a
las escuelas y salen de las escuelas y
los paradigmas que sustentan las
prácticas pedagógicas de los directores
y de los profesores y de todo un
instituto de educación muchas veces
están anquilosadas son muy tradicionales
que terminan de alguna manera aburriendo
al alumnado vale porque tenemos que
estudiar estudiar y estudiar para
después terminar que de vomitado de
alguna manera en un examen nos queda
nada vale porque porque muchas veces la
educación es enciclopedista y
memorística hoy por hoy gracias a que
existen también personas que piensan
mucho en esto dijeron pues mira vamos a
empezar a crear determinadas
metodologías que de alguna manera
impacten en el niño y que esas
metodologías les sirvan al niño a
construir aprendizajes y esos
aprendizajes sean significativos
la realidad es que durante muchos años
hemos cambiando paradigmas educativos
pero la realidad es la que nos muestra
muchas veces las gráficas
esta es una gráfica del 2015 la
deserción escolar españa está a la
cabeza de la deserción escolar un 23 5%
de los estudiantes españoles desertan
del sistema hay un hay un índice muy
alto de deserción escolar vamos a
uruguay a ver cómo es la realidad
uruguay la realidad de uruguay es que
cada 100
alumnos que entran a secundaria
solamente termina el 29% es terrible
esto es terrible y no para terrible no
solamente para un chaval sino que es
terrible para un país
porque el 70 por ciento de los jóvenes
están fuera del sistema escolar la
pregunta es qué es lo que pasa con el
sistema educativo que expulsa a los
alumnos del sistema y no los retiene
dentro del sistema quizás tendríamos que
pensar en términos emocionales y la cosa
cambiaría
pensar por un momento que existen una
cantidad de situaciones que se dan en el
aula que repercuten no solamente en los
aprendizajes sino en la vida de la
persona
está comprobado una de estas cosas que
les decía es la de la depresión la
depresión y la ansiedad se considera que
para el 2020 la depresión va a estar tan
alto en las cifras que va a estar
delante del sida son altísimas las
cifras hay niños que van a la escuela y
están ansiosos van ansioso estás
sobreestimulados porque ya saben le
asestaba en escribir y van a la escuela
y tienes primero y te encuentras con un
niño que ya lo sabe todo y que puede
hacer que me aburro now raise the fuck
este que aburrida y donde sea que el
niño es una inquietud continua y de
repente decimos pues este niño es muy
inquieto algo le está pasando no será un
test de as por ahí
y no sabemos y no es que claro sobre
exigimos a los niños tenemos aquellos
niños a agenda y al final no le
dedicamos lo más importante que es el
tiempo el tiempo para estar con la
familia el tiempo para compartir el
tiempo para mirarnos a los ojos cuantas
veces por ahí vamos a le preguntamos al
uno y que se echó esta tarde en casa que
se ha hecho ayer pues nada ido a mi casa
he estado en mi casa y mi madre me ha
dado la tablet y ahora del supa que es
fed pues nada mi madre estaba con el
móvil mi padre y también y yo cuando le
preguntaba alguna cosa pues me decía
espera que contestó el whatsapp y
después hablamos es que es terrible y
los niños lo cuentan todo los niños lo
dicen absolutamente todo y tú vas y
dices tenemos que estar con los hijos
porque saben qué pasa que si no estamos
con los hijos hoy vamos a querer estar
mañana y mañana tu hijo te va a decir
papá ahora no tengo tiempo estoy en mi
habitación que estoy hiperconectado con
este mundo virtual que me está generando
a mí más gratificaciones que hablar
contigo
no perdamos el tiempo
una de las cosas más importantes que
está pasando ahora es que 47 billones de
dólares se utilizarán en los próximos 20
años para paliar este tipo de
situaciones de depresión y ansiedad
vamos mal vamos mal qué es lo que pasa
qué respuesta le podemos dar nosotros
desde el ámbito educativo nosotros vemos
todos estos estas situaciones de riesgo
social de conductas disruptivas de
violencia de bullying y ciber bullying
que muchas veces se dan en nuestras
escuelas esas imágenes que muchas veces
son pensadas en la red sin ningún tipo
de empatía vemos que existe una
respuesta desde la educación enfoque
emocional y no desde la educación formal
nosotros en este en nuestro colegio de
la extracción de montserrat la psicóloga
del colegio virginia espejo lleva a cabo
una formación en todos los alumnos sobre
educación emocional partimos de un
paradigma muy básico un paradigma muy
sencillo que lo apliquen o no por
sencillo quiere decir este demasiado
simple no es sencillo para poder ser
aplicados son modelos educativos de
programa educación emocional que parten
de la idea de que el niño tiene que
conocer sus emociones identificadas
regular las partimos de la idea de la
educación emocional si bien la educación
emocional tiene un sustrato en la
inteligencia emocional de daniel goleman
vale consideramos más apropiado poder
hablar de educación emocional porque
porque la inteligencia es un constructo
de alta integración cortical así como es
la atención la memoria la percepción tú
no tienes y lo puedes construir en los
años pero el concepto de educación parte
de la idea de que todos podemos ser
educados en las emociones
y cómo educamos en las emociones en una
escuela como lo hacemos pues lo primero
que hacemos es identificamos las
emociones las emociones básicas le
enseñamos al niño identifica la alegría
la tristeza la rabia el asco por qué
porque nos hemos dado cuenta que muchas
veces le preguntábamos al niño y tú cómo
te encuentras yo cómo te encuentras hoy
este movimiento con el hombro nos da la
impresión de que el niño no sabe
expresar con palabras cómo se siente no
sabe decir que está contento no sabe
decir que está alegre vale entonces
nosotros comenzamos desde los 3 años a
enseñar a los niños a conocer sus
emociones básicas luego que conocen sus
emociones básicas lo que hacemos es
tratar de que el niño las pueda regular
pueda controlar estas emociones como las
controla pues a través de técnicas
cuando estaba en uruguay trabajé durante
14 años en una escuela también del
barrio borro
y de repente iba a la clase y dos por
tres algunos niños se estaban peleando
por aquí otro que le tiraba la silla al
otro y claro en este ambiente pues no
puedes dar clase entonces dedicaba mucho
tiempo pedagógico a poder solucionar
estos problemas porque claro si la clase
no está tranquila porque vas a educar
que vas a enseñar por qué porque un niño
emocionalmente estable está preparado
para aprender lo mismo pasa con nosotros
si nosotros estamos emocionalmente
estables tiramos para adelante con lo
que sea y como estamos emocionalmente
estables muchas veces tenemos nuestras
propias fortalezas y otras veces lo que
me viene del exterior me ayuda qué es lo
que nos viene del exterior las palabras
las palabras hay palabras que generan
vida
cuando estaba en segundo año de escuela
quedé repetido ahora porque no sabía
leer me costaba leer eran épocas
difíciles en uruguay porque en la época
de dictadura militar teniendo en cuenta
la situación en la que yo vivía pues no
tenía una madre que me enseñara a leer
ni que estuviera conmigo no entendía que
las palabras estaban formadas por letras
no entendía que cada letra tenía un
sonido no sabía que dos letras juntas
formaban una sílaba esto ni idea
y entonces que de repetidora y en las
épocas dictaduras militar pues nos
hacían formar filas como los soldados y
una maestra que me dejó repetido ahora
le dice a la otra que me cogía mira
carmen es muy buena pero la cabeza no le
da
hasta hoy me acuerdo porque hay palabras
que tranca en una rueda y hay otras
palabras que impulsan un carro
como estamos nosotros impulsamos el
carro trancamos ruedas a nivel educativo
y esa es la idea de la educación
emocional intentar que los niños
conozcan sus emociones regulen sus
emociones se genere la empatía y la
autoestima necesaria en los adolescentes
para tener conductas asertivas les
enseñamos a los niños a saber decir no a
decir sí por ahí tú les dejes y creo que
este tipo de conductas asertivas pues
mira cuando te ofrecen una droga que vas
a decir te quieres tu a ti mismo que vas
a decir les comenzamos a enseñar y
explicar la importancia de quererse a
uno mismo porque ya lo decían los
antiguos griegos sabes si alguno ha ido
a griesa grecia está el oráculo de
delfos con una puerta y una inscripción
que dice conócete a ti mismo si te
conoces a ti mismo sabrás cuáles son tus
potencialidades tus dificultades qué es
lo que te gusta qué es lo que no te
gusta y hacia dónde vas a caminar y qué
sentido le encontrarás a esta vida que
tienes porque la vida sin sentido no es
una vida
es una vida que está vacía que vas
viviendo porque el tiempo va pasando
queremos enseñarle a nuestros alumnos a
nuestros hijos a encontrar un sentido a
las cosas a tener un objetivo y sigo
porque a mí se me va la olla muchas
veces en todo esto y que no estaba por
aquí resultados de esta investigación
nosotros hemos realizado una
investigación en este colegio estación
de monserrat que les decía dónde
a través de dos profesoras que fueron
muy intuitivas en el tema dijeron por
qué no aplicamos un programa de
educación emocional vale el colegio en
tracción vos ahora no es un colegio que
tenga riesgos a nivel de conductas
disruptivas no es un colegio de riesgo
social su colegio pues que haya alguna
algunos problemas pero no los necesarios
como para decir vamos a impactar en esta
población porque vemos que las cosas no
van no aplicamos este programa educación
emocional como una innovación pedagógica
que tenía como características prevenir
este tipo de situaciones y entonces
comenzamos a aplicarlo al cabo de un
tiempo a mí se me ocurre hacer una
investigación porque bueno quería
presentar una tesis para un más te digo
bueno mira vamos a investigar a ver cómo
están estos alumnos entonces aplique
unos instrumentos de evaluación
homologados que son los que éste evalúan
las emociones entonces estos son uno de
los resultados que nosotros obtuvimos
del 0 al 9 que vosotros vais a la
izquierda de la pantalla pues ese es la
escala likert no donde cinco más o menos
es la media de lo que va de cinco para
abajo
habilidades emocionales que el niño
todavía no está en el nivel de aceptable
y luego hacia arriba es lo positivo este
paradigma que les decía anteriormente
trabajamos estas cinco competencias
emocionales vale la conciencia emocional
que era conocer primero las emociones
regular las emociones la autonomía la
competencia y qué era lo que se pretende
lo que se pretende en definitiva es que
el niño sea competente a nivel emocional
para poder vivir en una sociedad con un
cierto bienestar esta es la idea de la
educación emocional aquí como podéis ver
el color talón ya es el nuestro colegio
y el otro colegio el otro es un colegio
que nosotros hemos tomado su matriz de
datos para poder contrarrestar datos
porque como habíamos empezado ha
iniciado un proceso de educación
emocional pero no habíamos evaluado las
competencias iniciales de nuestros
alumnos por lo tanto no teníamos datos
para poder comprobar cómo estaban al
comienzo a nuestros alumnos cogimos una
matriz de datos de un colegio muy
parecido al nuestro que ya había hecho
y un póster y lo que hicimos fue
comparar los resultados y bueno y
salimos bastante bien en algunas
habilidades en las otras estamos
trabajando la idea de todo esto es en
definitiva es que vosotros os vayáis
pensando a vuestra casa a los que sois
estudiantes o los que estáis trabajando
en el ámbito de la educación pensar que
somos seres emocionales antes que seres
académicos pensar que la educación así
como decía mandela que la educación
académica es importante nosotros decimos
que la educación académica y la
educación emocional son las armas más
poderosas del mundo pues muchas gracias
[Aplausos]